[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is a
delight this episode is a delight it's
me sitting down with my new friend Craig
Conant who I met when he did Montreal he
did new faces last year and I was
hosting and I was blown away by his set
and I've been a fan of his ever since uh
if you don't know Craig check out his
podcast it's called community service
he's just always a delight and this was
just the exactly the kind of episode
that I was hoping for fun light easy and
then just the right amount of deep
interesting spiritual fun so I love it
he's so fun it was a delight to hang out
with him and I'm so happy to be able to
share that with all of you so check him
out uh check out community service if
you'd like to see me doing stand-up
comedy I'm doing more and more of it
these days uh I have a special coming
out in October on Netflix so I'm working
my new hour if you'd like to see that
process which is in my opinion some of
the most exciting and interesting
stand-up as at the beginning when you're
working it out and kind of finding it
with the crowd my next show at Largo I
do a monthly show at Largo here in Los
Angeles is on September 2nd but we do
that every month so whenever you hear
this uh just go to
largo.la.com and look for Pete Holmes
living at Largo always so fun thank you
to everybody that's been coming out to
those it's incredible the highlight of
my month every month
and I'm also going to be in Denver
um next week next weekend we just added
a late show on Thursday because the
other show sold out so I hope people can
come out to that late show on Thursday
it's going to be so fun me and Matt
McCarthy it's wonderful I hope you can
go go to petehomes.com for tickets to
that after Denver is St Louis and then
there'll be more and more dates that
we'll be adding as they are announced so
go to petehomes.com at any time yeah and
if you don't know if you don't know by
now we don't do traditional ads on this
podcast we only do sponsorships with
things that I actually use and actually
love and uh I don't know if you know
this about me I'm a pretty healthy guy
I'm mindful about what I put in my body
but years ago I realized I wasn't being
careful about what I put on my body
which of course ends up in your body
that's that's how your body works but I
was out there buying shaving creams and
face washes and frankly I thought were
good high quality because they had I
don't know French names I bought them at
a mall kiosk or they were expensive or
whatever but they're not they're filled
with chemicals crammed in there by
corporations that don't care about you
or your health toxicity levels that were
never intended for your skin or your
mouth your eyes your hair you know
whatever your gums I can get that stuff
out of there it's not intended for human
consumption so I realized I wanted my
food to have ingredients that I could
read and recognize and understand I want
my skin care to be the same so enter
living Libations living Libations is not
only the best and most effective badass
real life skin care hair eye teeth even
baby care products that I've ever found
but they're also the most natural made
exclusively with plants and oils and
extracts that not only will you
recognize but you'll be able to easily
pronounce and now that it's summer
having a natural zinc based sunblock for
our child and for ourselves is so
important I've noticed when you Google
natural sunblock it's there most of them
that come up are just claiming to be
natural they're not but living Libations
their love the sun sunblock is zinc
based not only works but feels great and
works great and lasts a really really
long time on your skin and a little
bottle of it also lasts a really really
long time this is a great way to support
the show even if you don't want sunblock
they have something to replace
everything we use their best skin ever
moisturizer I use their gum care it's
called neem curly Bubble Gum Care their
toothpaste they have a amazing different
whatever you need if you have something
in your medicine cabinet that you're
kind of looking at sideways and not
trusting so much go to living Libations
they have a premium natural and
wonderful product to replace the random
chemical nightmare that you might buy at
like 7-Eleven so go for 15 off go to
livinglibations.com weird show your
support for your body your skin your
hair your eyes your nails your teeth and
show your support of the show 15 off
livinglibations.com weird alright
everybody enjoy my chat with Craig
Conant
get into it Free Soap but also
cheddar cheese
potato cheddar cheese they make cheese
too but they make cheese and we make
cheese yeah no Dr Bronner's uh
high road to death we shouldn't even be
talking about it's free I know it's all
right we love you no we do love them
organic I also just like that the bar is
so go ahead non-corrupted magic mine no
two camera wait which one's yours that
one's you
oh
it's gotten to the point where guests
now expect and look forward to trying
magic mine when they do the show which
is great because I I absolutely my first
time and this is modern mammals because
you got that good hair oh yes this is
the best shampoo ever yeah
I do sometimes that was a bit of a joke
but yes I have for sure I have it's good
for you a coconut oil
but this shampoo doesn't it doesn't
matter we don't have to talk about that
okay you bumped the wide Kim
it's just um just a bit messy a bit
greasy the headboards got some oil on it
yeah because you're getting rode hard
and you're just your own head your own
head is just more castor oil
it's a thing your hair looks great you
look great I love a sweatshirt I know
I've been making money now I've been
getting good that's what you do good
clothing you could buy good clothing are
we rolling yeah okay nice I love this I
was gonna say I love that Dr Bronner
says um
uh all one on it yes because that's I
I'm a I'm a non-dualist so I like that I
don't know if you're familiar we don't
have I don't even know what non-dualist
I love this stuff that's why I love you
oh man I love you okay well let me start
here [__] all that stuff that's way too
long we'll get into non-duality I love
you I think you're so talented and when
I saw I hosted new faces we're not
rolling I'm just kidding we're rolling
this nice compliment no but I mean it so
sincerely I hosted new faces when you
were doing it and I watched your set and
I was like what is what is happening
like meaning you should be huge and I
think you will be huge and I think
you're already big but I think you're
gonna be huge thank you and I think you
it will be deserved and you're unique
and interesting and funny and Incredibly
likable and that's all I got well thank
you I love you it's hard for me to take
compliments but I'm doing better at that
is that right with the help of YouTube
and Dr Wayne and Dyer is that right yeah
I love that full but uh I'll never
forget that I don't know if you remember
this I just done my set and it went very
well and uh yeah it did go you came to
me and you're like like and you're
giving me a compliment you're like hey
and you said something like every joke
can be uh like your first joke oh yeah
which is I okay sorry to compliment my
own compliment but I think a joke that
you can just do without like already
being on a roll is kind of the rarest
kind of joke like a joke that can open a
set yeah so when I said that I meant
that as like holy [__] like what what
I'm saying when I'm on a roll 30 minutes
in of to a set you can start doing jokes
that wouldn't have worked at the
beginning your because it would have
been too out of nowhere it wouldn't have
been the right foot to get started on
all of your jokes were like you could
open with that you could open with that
you could open with that and it's
incredible yeah it's incredible they're
all like stand-alone little pieces but
you said
because I remember you were telling me
this and I completely understood but I
just got off stage yeah I was very
emotional it was my first big break so
to speak yeah weird time for this face
to be like hey Craig did you notice how
I look how I look and I was just like
this and you're like do you understand
me and I was like I understand I'm just
about to cry right now man and then I
went behind the curtain I just weeped of
joy you did yeah yeah no that's great
yeah you can feel that oh yeah you got
completely blocked no you can cry a
little bit oh yeah that's great I'd be
crying in the car quite often it's
something about the car and the open
road I agree and a good song you just go
the possibilities the possibilities
you're literally moving forward you're
moving forward it's what you've always
wanted to take me home you know
I also just think driving occupies a
part of your brain that would otherwise
be used to block feelings so that
mechanism that's out there swatting down
don't think about your dad don't think
about that first love that way and now
it has to drive the car so it's like
[__] he's unguarded so I think there's
something to be said about creativity
when you're driving yeah I also cry on
the Peloton the the bike that's similar
though
man like mine's good you're in
you're in your body and you're listening
to powerful music music that I never put
on
I put on music that won't bother me
that's kind of like neutral low energy
yeah I put on and it's funny that you
said Enya I put on any of the other day
and it was a kind of a joke like I
thought it would make my wife laugh that
was like oh can't say then I just left
it on for 20 minutes that's no joke and
you feel good and you feel good I don't
even know who my new artist is but she
sings this song I Release Control oh my
God that's great it's fantastic what a
great message too yeah that's it I know
and that's so crying on the Peloton but
I get I kind of ugly cry on the Peloton
I get out like a sound do you ever get a
sound guard you're sweating and crying
you can't tell where the wet's coming
from you're just moist what's the sound
it sounds like it's like it's ugly and
sometimes my wife and my daughter will
come in and I'm just so glad they're not
there with Debs he's up on them
and you know what daddy is okay I I
broke down a little bit we were visiting
home and uh my parents and I like to
make that distinction where I live now
is my home yeah
I was visiting my old home my parents
and my parents they're very hard to
please and that can be very hopeless I
don't not to get too serious but it can
be hard to make an event that they will
enjoy yeah you would say I was supposed
to say my parents for the same they're
just hard you're just like can't you
just say good job
you went right to it you went right to
it something [__] nice
my dad saw me and he walked backstage
and like here it comes I got Standing
Ovation yeah a thousand people yeah and
you just go and I told a story about him
and all he said about the show he's
pulling he's always perpetually pulling
up his pants he's just that never
happened he just immediately starts
attacking my story and my story The
Point Craig the point of the story is
that I'm telling something that he
didn't know was happening yeah like the
point of the story is that you wouldn't
know you're not the judge of the
storyline oh my God but I'm worth and
this is gonna no wonder we're both
Comedians and we both cry in the car
dude the older I get the more I'm just
kind of like I spend so much of my life
going like you don't have to be messed
up to be a comedian and now I'm like
we're all messed up but comedians are
messed up in a specific way yeah that's
okay yeah love me if you want strangers
to know you you were probably felt a
little unknown yeah and if you want
strangers to love you you might have
felt a little unloved I think mine is
the first one any hoosel so my wife
bless people say bless her heart in a
condescending way I really mean it bless
her heart is trying to think of things
we can do after the lunch that might be
fun that my mom might enjoy I'm in a
desperate sad place where I'm like
there's no
fun ice cream there's no like wherever
we go it will be this it'll just be like
we'll just change the background yeah so
it's a desperate and hopeless feeling
and my wife is like maybe we can get
yeah it was no fun to be had we're going
with my mother that's how I feel like oh
you fool I don't care if we're at Chuck
E cheese that's it Valerie I'm glad you
think there's a place we can go where
this will be okay and there isn't and
that's how I feel Val might be right I
might just be so blocked in my own
thinking but I'm I don't have the energy
to do it to push a manicure session up a
hill and have fun yeah maybe if I put on
a song and dance and like tap dance and
make jokes and like take all the onus on
me so anyway she goes maybe we can get a
manicure and I just started crying
because we're we're about to start a
lunch that wasn't gonna work yeah and
then she's like maybe after this we can
get a manicure and I'm like which is
extending all I want to hear is like
after this we can get out of here you
know it's like it's like let's extend
and I just kind of it wasn't like a full
crowd it wasn't even a Peloton cry which
is kind of like a
like that and I didn't want my daughter
to see because she was under the table
Rock and it was some crayons and then
Val was like no you should let her see
you should show her that it's okay
that sometimes you feel overwhelmed
isn't that great yeah like they should
walk in on me on the Peloton God loved
them yeah yeah if they can see me the
only time I saw my dad cry was when you
listen to Mike and the mechanics on the
radio in the car yeah go I'm gonna take
my jacket off no my dad didn't cry
either my mom said she saw him cry one
time over a dog over a dog yeah Enoch
yeah he's knocked his dog's name was
Enoch isn't that one of the pilots on
the Nebuchadnezzar that I don't even
know he's a spaceship in the Matrix he's
uh he's from Boston and oh no my dad's
from Boston yeah blonde hair blue I like
his drink like his smoke like the Gamble
oh no it grew up in the moose and the
Elks and the VFW what's the VFW the
veteran of Foreign Wars but it's a bar
it's like a non-profit bar where you
could gamble in the back and say bad
things
that's where my childhood was no yeah a
little bit I mean a lot a bit yeah a lot
of it yeah we spend some time there wait
you'd go to the bar with your dad yeah
and he'd be with his veteran friends
he's not even a veteran he just liked
the discount beer and he would take
their money he liked it oh he liked to
beat the veterans yeah yeah so they
served him twice
it's like you serve me over season now
you're gambling you're gonna buy me a
coffee yeah
gambling what
just like uh everything whatever sports
hockey baseball football horses he love
horses carts they had like slot machines
in the back we used to go to machine
shops where the guy would just have like
Vegas slots and they'd shoot out Court
it was the 90s it was different you know
yeah yeah but that yeah I just remember
me even being a kid would be like this
is crazy you know like yeah kind of like
this business
in L.A not anymore I'm actually it
probably is but I don't know of them
anymore only when I was eight because
they're not wait you were even out here
when you were eight yeah when I was
eight years old I was pulling the slot
machine lever and I was spitting out
quarters in in Los Angeles what yeah I'm
not kidding yeah
because you were winning I could say it
was like Ray's machine shop in Vermont
and on Vermont and Torrance Boulevard in
Los Angeles yeah over there and you were
getting lucky or it was broken no we
were getting lucky Yeah well yeah
because we had good energy we were kids
we weren't tarnished yet and all the all
the oh geez I remember hitting the
jackpot I was a little kid yeah because
you don't have an unconscious desire to
lose and I hit like a jackpot I won 150
bucks and all the old drunks were mad at
me like this kid just comes in here and
he takes this money and that was my
jackpot I was smoking inside the bar
still at eight no they were hey I'm
sorry I'm not being supposed no not me I
never got into cigarettes a lot of weed
though
when did you start that wait first of
all let's unpack that
because that's kind of a scary situation
you won 150 I've been at a blackjack
table where I was playing Blackjack
poorly and the guy next to me was mad
because let's say I hit on 17 or
something I broke some rule yeah yeah
and then the next card was a king and it
busted and he wanted that King and then
I I busted and then he hit and he got
like a three and he was like well now
I'm [__] he was like openly mad at me
yeah people don't talk about gambling
anger because you're no one look I don't
know I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
nobody gambling
maybe maybe a few billionaires are doing
it like happily but most people are
doing it from a place of like anger and
sadness I'll go get my rent back you can
walk through the floor yes the floor in
Vegas there's a lot of like it's not a
fun place slow Vibe and even if you win
the guy next to you is mad yeah you took
his card so you win 150 and a bunch of
drunk guys smoking
are mad at you and you you just took it
yeah
I won Baron Square I pulled the lever
unfair and square yeah you happen to be
the one it all was illegal they can't be
like guard them we're in Los Angeles
that's what makes it even spicier is
that it's like you can't if they were if
they robbed you yeah you can't call the
cops and be like they stole my money
that I got from this illegal machine
like you know what I mean it's like
illegality begets more illegality and no
honor Amongst Thieves I guess is the
other way until I say these stories out
loud I realize how weird it is you know
you're just like I guess yes and yet
familiar yeah when you say that I'm just
sort of like yeah
you know you're kind of lucky because
it's like a better scene in a movie but
that's how all of our childhood felt
hanging out with Dad whether or not you
were rocking it on a slot machine felt
like rocking it on a slot machine does
that make sense yes even if that's not
what was literally happening my dad was
out there bending rules breaking rules
it was a weird feeling yeah very
different from Mom yes mom's a square
wouldn't jaywalk seen her drunk twice in
my life like just a real just jaywalk
she's just an old-fashioned old-school
Mexican lady very scared of everything
that huh you know I swear
does she ever throw out a Deal's meal or
yeah was that inappropriate
and she said to me I fragon yeah that
means like this this freaking kid I fly
this [__] punk oh no no I was a
whippersnapper but yeah you earned a few
dsdios in your time so she's terrified
and she married why did she marry this
man I don't know complete opposites just
just uh she married like a crazy look
I'm saying you're not saying I'm saying
I love him buddy blonde hair blue-eyed
Boston and yeah lunatic out there maybe
I would say that as a joke I'm afraid of
them
and I was like no
no good and fair he's a good man but
he's crazy yeah yeah and how did he meet
your mom uh they knew no uh knew who the
magic man where you at
Manchester okay just eat it like a hot
sauce dragon
uh go on um they met in high school at
Narbonne High in uh in Los Angeles okay
Harbor City whatever Lomita and then uh
they dated throughout the years and then
at 29 they're like let's get married I
don't I don't know if it was uh
I don't know I I there wasn't much love
I don't know growing up I don't think uh
between them yeah they didn't like each
other
uh I mean they didn't get along it was
just yeah they didn't it's just a lot of
yeah
buddy my joke used to be my parents are
still together unfortunately that's the
joke yeah are your parents still
together no who passed Ray who owned the
machine shop or your dad oh my dad's
still with us Ray that owned the machine
okay so I'm still afraid of your dad
we can talk [__] about Ray I guess
what are you Donatello you love machines
get out of it you're getting arrested
man he's passed yeah no he's got illegal
gambling oh that's what his habitat says
why would he put that on the stone
weird I think we should look into that
so your parents were fighting a lot and
do you have siblings yes two older
sisters they're five and seven years
older oh yeah they tortured me it was
funny
was it no they super glued my lips
together twice
uh it's it's him I swear to God
it was awful and then I remember no it
is awful how did they do it do you do
this in your stand up to you and we're
gonna do it you bring up things and I
have a million follow-up questions and
you're just on no one knows how you do
that did they coerce you that's one
style like we're gonna do something
funny like we're gonna we wanna put lip
gloss on you and you're like oh okay or
did they pin you down and do it no they
tricked me it's always trickery uh-huh
first time I was too little I don't
really remember the second time I
remember I remember trying my I remember
my nana tried to put hot water on my
lips and I was like hmm and then the
second time my mom just did it with it
with the knife and just with a knife
because I was panicking you know and my
nose was getting snotty but I was
laughing and crying and I remember two
little boogers shot out on the ground
and it was two perfect circles of snot
and then we were laughing at that as I
couldn't breathe and was like well your
mom was laughing too me and my sisters
and then my mom came in and I just I
remember having bloody lips that's all I
remember I was probably like five and
seven or something okay yeah which one
of these is the trauma cam
that is just traumatic
and the and the mixing for you of the
laughing like you were laughing yeah so
you know what I mean it's like you're
being gassed to death and there's
laughing gases
because a lot the blending of that had
to be really difficult to unpack yeah
and then after she freed you with a
knife and there's two perfect circles of
snot on the ground was there like were
they in trouble
um I don't think so
because I agreed to it like if that was
like the rules like wait you agreed yeah
I'm like I think I remember stuff like
lessons like that like from my dad like
well you agreed to it like don't agree
to it you know I can't punish them or
maybe a little bit it was nothing made
sense nothing made sense thank you I'm
glad that you figured that out that
doesn't make sense well the child signed
off yeah like like literally this is why
they made that expression if everybody
was jumping off a bridge would you do it
when you're five yeah yeah you would
yeah because you'd be like they seem to
know what they're doing like you're
learning everything from everyone the
yeah the list is long what they did to
me uh these two girls yeah I love them
to death they saved my life many many
times over and and from stuff they did
yeah well he agreed to it but we should
still we should still save him uh so
you're good with them now oh yeah we're
super close like two lips super glued
together that close yeah yeah we're
going to San Diego after this family
vacation really yeah well that's great
yeah I also just noted that the age is
rough five years is a is a lot older so
you're not really they had each other
and I was
was the loan but like and a boy alone
and young a baby boy yeah and when you
showed up were you A disruption to the
whole family no my dad was uh he had to
have a son he was sprouting them out
until he had a son yeah one of those two
yeah yeah yeah there would have been
five like Nebuchadnezzar before him or
Caesar I'm a junior Craig Phillip Conant
Jr yeah
buddy my my brother is a Jew he's not a
junior but he's a third that's another
way of doing it same thing we've talked
about this before but I'm like
how much pressure is it that your dad is
like your yeah me yeah or did you like
it maybe no no
there was a time in my life that I was
like I'm not the third my brother's a
third and then eventually when I was
like eight or nine I was like oh good
because there was pressure it's like
your pressure yeah that was for sure
pressure it was it was just yeah you
know what else did your sisters do to
you they made me drink perfume it was in
like an advertisement bottle did you
agree to it
okay so you're complicit keep going you
agreed to it your child I think I threw
up immediately because they had an
advertisement I think it was Obsession
remember that old fragrance session and
a model was drinking it out of it with
the straw like that was the ad oh and
they're like see this model drinks it
you could drink it too and I was just
like okay like you have a lawsuit on
your hands you can't show was there fine
print yeah probably this is like Pepsi
where's my jet which was the I did you
watch Pepsi where's [__] don't watch
it they draw out a 40-minute story into
like five one hour episodes and you're
just like
I won't even bore you uh keep going you
drank it and threw up immediately drank
you threw up immediately they tricked me
into drinking Phillips Milk of Magnesia
which gives you diarrhea because my
middle name's Philip and they're like it
says Philip and it tasted minty so I was
always drinking so they're always
getting diarrhea and then
they they uh
all of it they did The Three Stooges the
put the you know yeah sure and then
blood just started
yeah because everything The Three
Stooges do to each other if you really
did it like a hammer in your nose I hate
The Three Stooges they represent
everything that's wrong with everything
yeah you heard someone and then you're
like get the [__] out of here you're in
the way you're stopping human evolution
[__] bull-cutted mean face like a
face that says I've been abused in my
whole life I've never had a fair thing
happen to me and I'm gonna take it out
on my friends get over here hit him with
a board oh that was a nail in it sorry
curly
Stooges all that old school [__] WC
Fields yeah all of it feels so mean to
me it is really mean it's mean I'm not
saying there isn't a place for it but
every like in Boston too everyone loved
the Three Stooges so when I was into
comedy they were like you must love this
and I was like there's three men that
seem to be fighting over the last meal
on Earth yeah like they're fighting for
their own Survival in black and white
right but you liked it NWC Fields yeah
and Abbott and Costello they were less
mean right
yeah yeah who's on first dudes and then
Jackie Gleason The Honeymooners he he I
had a eclectic childhood I'm grateful
for that like just the stuff Nana of
course I know Perry Como is you know are
just like weird [__] can we step out
just for a moment and appreciate that
one of the most famous routines of all
time who's on first requires
that before you see the routine you see
the baseball diamond with the labels oh
do you remember or you maybe you don't
have to remember yeah I played baseball
so I didn't need it
no I don't mean to understand
I maybe okay I'm realizing that I'm
wrong but when you see that routine is
on a loop in Cooperstown where the
Baseball Hall of Fame is and next to it
there's a diagram showing you like who's
the name of the guy on first is who I
don't know is on second and whatever's
on Third and I just realized that I
thought they walked the audience through
that before the routine but they didn't
no they got it back then nowadays they
need the diagram to explain to the tick
tockers what baseball is that's true
yeah baseball is the opposite of tick
tock yeah it's way longer than a minute
oh yeah it doesn't care if you're
interested did you play baseball I did I
was the catcher nice I played a short
stop Third Base yes he seemed like a
you're like a cooler guy you're out
there like making a difference catcher's
a wall
you could be replaced by a soft wall you
flatter yourself that everyone's in a
while you whip your mask off and look
for a pop-up don't listen to your
parents you are worthy you're not a wall
you know what a catcher is a catcher is
you know how a toll booth can just be a
basket you throw a change in yeah and
then next my friend genre used to have a
joke about how on New Year's Eve there's
no one sadder than a toll booth
collector on New Year's Eve 30 feet away
there's a basket doing the same job
that's how I feel about being a catcher
yeah that's true you could just be
nothing yeah
never happened over the head over the
head I'd throw it into center field give
them third I hated I hated being bad at
baseball yeah I think because of that
I'm still kind of afraid of things that
I'm bad at I know everybody is to a
certain extent but I'm like oh it'll be
embarrassing if I try no we have to be
perfect at everything that's right you
know when there's like a stand-up show
where they're like and then at the end
you sing a song I'm like I'm not
available yeah even though I love I like
singing I can't but I'm like if I can't
nail it I'm like I don't want people to
be like oh it was funny he did it like
funny I'm like no I want them to cry the
goddamn Comedy Jam gets me crippling an
anxiety no thank you Josh yeah Josh I
can't do it God love him he's like come
do it and I'm like uh honestly I'm never
available and I'm like thank God I'm not
available
Nana was wild
Nana had three husbands buried them all
buried his son she's just uh oh OG was
born and can't be stopped yeah she went
to like 90. 6 or something and drank
like a fish like everything like I
remember 1996 she lived until 1996 yeah
and then the doctor was like you can't
drink anymore and everything was like
I'd rather die like that was her answer
wait we need to take your car away like
I'd rather die like it's a bit but it's
not a bit it's just that was her she
kept driving oh yeah past the point of
being alone you just wouldn't we had to
take it away she kept getting in
accidents of course and she would do hit
they get in Walking accidents no
he told me and my sister she drove
through the hospital a parking lot arm
and we asked like what happened she said
I wasn't sticking around to find out and
she just took out the parking Booth guy
can you imagine how many accidents
happen in the hospital parking lot
that's where the old people are going
also I had my awesome when they're sick
too they're fine yeah that's it and you
get your eyes dilated yeah and
everyone's like wait 45 minutes no one
person is like yeah I'll work every five
minutes I survived the war yeah I
couldn't make it home
she was alive during the Great
Depression she had money before that she
used to wear minks and had a chauffeur
and then it crashed and then she went to
Poverty so she'd be like give you like
50 cents right I mean you were like what
am I gonna do with this but it felt like
a million bucks to her I still don't
fully understand the Great Depression
meaning if your nana had a million
dollars in 1931 before the stock market
crashed but she has it it's not in the
stock market necessarily I guess it
would need an economist to explain them
but if she has a million dollars in the
bank I guess then the banks don't have
the money that's it I don't know I guess
the banks can't actually give you your
money so even rich people I was born
alive back then I should have asked her
more questions yeah but she would have
been drunk she wouldn't she would have
nowhere
yeah shut up nerd here's two quarters
was crazy but she introduced you to
Comedy Is that real
uh where I want to know when you started
smoking dope and I want to know when you
started figuring out that comedy was for
you I started smoking weed at 12 years
old how uh my sister
not to put her on blast but I was
bugging her and I was like hey oh what
you knew she was smoking yeah I I the
year before I thought it was like crack
and I told on her I ratted on her I was
like Cynthia's gonna die she has weed oh
yeah and then when I found out what it
was really was then I wanted to try it
and then and then she smoked me and my
buddy out and it was love at first sight
and it was what was the first one like I
couldn't stop laughing orange just never
tasted so good Goonies was never funnier
chunk was hitting this you know oh chunk
is made for a week yeah and uh oh Chung
it was and we topped Ramen and oranges
from my backyard and it was just heaven
and and it took away the the pain or
whatever no he did then you check out
for the next 20 years but I'm sober uh
10 years August 10th from narcotics and
alcohol I started wait you don't do weed
anymore I just I was just getting to
that I started so sweet I was 100 sober
for eight years and then I made it
through about half that pandemic and
then I started smoking weed again
because I didn't I needed something and
I didn't want to take head meds and
immediately uh what did what why what
what was the cue that you needed
something I started headlining and I
went from zero cities to 59 cities and I
don't I was I was it's really hard Pete
that's insane yeah that was my third
year you're not talking to somebody that
would be like that's the job I'd be like
that sounds like hell it it was too much
but I was running the pandemic it was in
the middle of yeah yeah so you're doing
like I got launched because of the
pandemic I say it's funny this is how
I've interpreted it yeah some of y'all
were too famous to go but I was I was
just coming up so it was bad PR
first for big dogs and then I was like
I'll go and then they literally I got in
everywhere and I was what are these
shows like outdoor or just Mast or all
of it like literally outdoor in Texas
indoors uh like you saw it all you saw
the different parking lots but you saw
the places where it was like we just
don't acknowledge it doing like an
actual Comedy Club but just in the
parking lot to places that were like we
don't care and uh really and then I
remember you didn't get it from those
shows no I I got it at home actually of
all places when I was the only time I
had a break was December and I got it
then didn't kova just show us that like
germs are like we just don't know like
we can so easily be taken down by germs
meaning sure do it outside do it there
and then you end up getting it at home
you know what I mean on the three weeks
I had off I got it at home and I was
like I was out there I was in Texas
indoors we communities too flying early
you know yeah and uh airplanes yeah
crazy airplane seems like where you
would go if you wanted Kobe yeah you
know what I mean but then it turns out
and then it just happens
right now wow so you started touring too
much I'll say it yes because your agent
was like let's go if you want to go you
were you in fairness I'm a Hungry Hungry
Hippo I just sat there I was like give
me the work and then they gave it to me
and I said yes and then halfway through
I was like oh [__] you agreed to it I'm
dying you're dead
and then I started smoking and it was a
beautiful medicine that helped me but
then I'm a little fiend and I
immediately started abusing it and and
then it switches to A coping mechanism
I'm an addict you know I have the attic
mind too I'm a self-diagnosed addict the
reason I stopped from saying I'm an
addict because I picture a room full of
real addicts being like you don't know
you don't have the certification levels
to it that's right that's what I mean
it's like just you don't I'm telling you
I'm wired that way I'm relating to you
and my I want to know if like
at the beginning you're telling yourself
it's like
you are kind of lying to yourself but
you have to you go like or you feel like
you have to you're like I need something
and I'll do it with these rules did you
have rules I had rules what were the
rules just uh
just as a medicine you know as it's
intended as it's supposed to be if if
you could have a healthy relationship
with it right and my tolerance is super
low so I could take like a little two
milligram gummy yep and be affected in a
beautiful way that's me by the way 2.5
yeah and it's lovely yeah but then I got
this hungry as soon as I get 2.5 this is
this is what attic feels like to me as I
go how far can we go how far can we take
that within six months I I was taking 25
by noon milligram you know two
milligrams to 25
and uh and then like drinking lemonades
that that had it I'm let back in and and
they have everything I'm gonna say
something kind of crazy is the perfume
lady the lady drinking obsession with a
straw that's weed stores being like do
you want a a KitKat and it's like it has
perfume in it you know what I mean like
it it has does the perfume get you high
yeah
and it's Obsession
I'm obsessed I think we're gonna look
back on this time that we're in right
now as insane for two reasons you know
how we watch Mad Men and we're like I
can't believe they were drinking all day
and smoking all day they're gonna look
at us and they're gonna be like I can't
believe they're had their phones which
are emitting microwaves and and
brainwashing you know speaking of which
I'll just throw it yeah and and weed
I look I really mean this without
judgment but like I just think weed is
really benefiting from an incredible
marketing campaign where you can be like
at a children's birthday party and be
like this is a little overwhelming for
me and then go smoke a joint come back
and just announce to the parents like I
feel a lot better just smoked yeah a
joint look
okay maybe yeah but I do think in the
future we're gonna walk watch that back
and be like that's Don Draper being like
this is a little much I'm gonna have
seven beers like it's I I think we just
don't hamster it's it's a trickster
because it's lemonade because it yeah
it's a KitKat that's my Coral with it
because it can be good in the proper
medicine like I made a joke like you
don't drink Dimetapp every day all day
you're not supposed to it's [__]
medicine right or Advil and Advil you're
not supposed to it's really bad for you
and anytime you switch that you ruin it
and that's what we do we just ruin it
we're Glutton this yeah and we can never
feed the beast and then your tolerance
goes up but if it is used occasionally I
can't do it I don't know how to again no
I am struggling I've been trying to quit
I made it a month and then I went back
and then like I'll make it three days
and like I'm yeah okay yeah it's hard
yeah no judgment here yeah I I think
it's beautiful that you're talking with
such clarity about it and also being
honest you're like I I hate my
relationship with it tell me everything
I just I hate that I feel like I need it
like I'm sober for this because I love
and respect you and I want it to be
sharp but I really wanted to smoke this
morning and that bugs me yeah you know
like why do I
have to fight so hard just to not take a
few what does the voice say I know
people a friend of mine that got sober
he told me like I'd go on a walk after I
got sober and I'd see a Sunset and was
beautiful and the voice would say be way
more beautiful if you're Stone right now
is that one of them what are the other
everything just like oh those dishes
will be more enjoyable to do the dishes
it's everything like oh Target it
doesn't matter what it is you're just
like I could be high for this I could be
the only thing I will never be high for
stand up is such a simple there's an
ache in that too it's it's not a funny
t-shirt but it's like a t-shirt that
says I could be high for that I don't
want to be yeah if I need to be yeah
like it's a shitty shitty thing I don't
like it what were you gonna say you
started to say stand up you can't be oh
like certain things I care about enough
uh they override like I won't be high on
stage even though I did try that a dozen
times and it doesn't work
once or twice and I I've said this
before but I want to see if it makes you
think of something the crowd became Orcs
I don't mean visually
they just seem like Lord of the Rings
like oh it's scary yeah and they were
friendly they were a good crowd but I
felt like I was throwing them like legs
of lamb yeah not jokes I was like
feeding them I don't enjoy friends yeah
no I don't know how those people will
just smoke and take the stage and I'm a
stone nurse since he's 12. yeah you do
it after you get off yes that's another
thing too like oh I can't wait till I'm
done with these shows buddy It's tricky
people get high so something that I have
this is absurd but like I like nicotine
I've never smoked in my life but I like
nicotine and one of the things I'm using
it again using it only when I'm writing
because I like it and the Temptation is
when you get off stage so your dopamine
just spiked and nicotine spikes your
dopamine I don't know what weed does to
your dopamine but I'm assuming it
increases it it's a feel-good chemical
if it's not dopamine it's another thing
but what's weird about substances just
in general is they are these feelings
usually reserved for some sort of feat
you go for a jog your your your body
awareness goes hey cardiovascular
healthy even though your body doesn't
know these words it's like that's
important that will keep him alive so
when he finishes a jog give him a good
feeling so he'll marry the idea that
when I go for a jog I get this feeling
you do stand up I think it might not be
his body it's more like a courage thing
it's like a bravery thing it's an
expression thing it's a creativity thing
it is deeply good for you no matter what
your Venue is to create and express
yourself and to and to push yourself uh
and not be afraid is really good for you
so your body gives you all of this like
hey you survived you did it you did
something that scared you so it gives
you the good feeling the risk even if
it's just a [__] glass of Coca-Cola
of marrying
the good feeling that your body is
giving you dopamine and you give it
another substance that increases
dopamine like Aerosmith used to talk
about cocaine they do cocaine and I saw
Stephen Tyler be like now I eat cream
puffs I'm like it's kind of the same
thing you're still high on dopamine and
you eat something else that gives you
dope I mean and then that's a tricky
marriage you know what I'm saying like
that's where so what all of them that's
interesting when I get off stage of
course I want to eat some nicotine gum I
just don't have it I'm like it's only in
my office it's only in a drawer I gotta
keep it the [__] away from me that's not
even true I have something in my pocket
right now just in case I felt a
withdrawal it's like emergency nicotine
but but I don't want to do what I have
done in the past which is like take
something that is good and marry it to
another dopamine increasing maybe I
never thought of it that way that's
interesting no I'm right I'm so ready to
quit weed again I said I was going to be
on it briefly and here we are like two
years at it I'm like [__] how did that
happen tell me go back to the part part
that that said I'm touring too much and
I need it it was because of stress oh I
might cry it was too many things bro oh
my uncle just passed from covid and Eric
Meyer is a dear friend of mine had just
passed and I was on the road and this
was happening and I can't cancel yeah I
could but like that's my daddy to get
this [__] done well there's his voice
did you agree to it I did but it's lips
glued together again you agreed to it
let's do it it's not a good chance bail
you are under no obligation to be the
person you were 15 seconds ago you know
but I don't mind that I like because I'm
I like being a man in my word and get
[__] done uh you know it's a certain
extent there's a there's a detrimental
to your health take a [__] break but
I was just got there you know imagine
your first time there and I was like I
can't I gotta get in gotta get in
anyways uh wait wait wait where's the
train of thought we're going to how weed
kind of helped with the stress oh yeah
two deaths like bang boom Road
loneliness Lonely No Road means
loneliness hard you're not touring with
anybody no I started to now a half the
time it's you know it's just costly and
we we've worked our way up it's crazy
yeah I want to say I don't I say it to
you but you want to say the opener and
be like you know the flight was 700 yeah
you know
yeah every every opener I've had I've
wanted to be like did you know your
hotel yeah
like yeah I know I'm giving you this for
the show do you know the hotel and the
flight was three times this like it's
rough but it's a mental health it's good
for you you know what body soul I say to
my my current opener I go it's worth
every penny it's it's worth twice what
it is because you go like Steve Martin
you go crazy yeah that's what it is so
you're trying to do that now the
loneliness how do you feel about the
shows
at that time I was nervous because it
was my first time running hours but it
all worked out I I had it with me yeah
yeah and uh so it was just a lot of
nerves pressure to sell tickets deaths
the world shutting down and not knowing
what's happening and then I started
smoking and it did help me uh profoundly
you know the expression that's good till
it's not or it works still it doesn't
it's fun until it's not like fun anymore
it's a common saying in the program yeah
yeah I'm not supposed to yeah I'll say
yeah yeah it doesn't matter who cares it
saves lives go do it if you have a
problem yeah why do they want not to be
named I don't know it's beautiful and we
know they're like what it is they're
like the Girl Scout cookies it's like
we're only available one month or don't
talk about us it's Fight Club basically
yeah
and uh and it did help and then it
quickly switched to abuse maybe a month
or two and what is that how did you cry
what does it look like to cross the
threshold you wake up and you smoke yeah
because you'll be sober by the time the
show starts yeah I relate so hard to
that that was me and booze I was like
I'll be I'll sleep at three o'clock yeah
and I'll wake up at seven o'clock and
I'll be sober and I was like looking
back I'm like what the [__] are you
doing you're not supposed to have two
days in a day you know what I mean and
neither of them are actually dead do the
same [__] just smoking away I'll get a
nap shower and a nap and I'll be sober
by the show why don't you just live your
[__] day well what does it feel like
to live your [__] day see what I
would say to myself at that time is What
feelings are you unwilling to feel in
your your story right now grief you lost
a friend and an uncle yeah so that must
lead to some sort of like
meaninglessness like we're all kind of
just headed towards that anyway don't
let me put words in your mouth how does
that feel I've always been a hippie I
actually wanted to ask you this uh I've
always believed in Oneness I ate a
quarter of mushrooms at like 15 years
old you start to think differently you
know and uh 16 or whatever and uh
so I know what a time it is we're all
one and it's all love and Consciousness
and we just go home and this is a
temporary experience yeah fan of Bill
Hicks yeah and your and your boy Ram Das
and all those fools yeah yeah throwing
dire Luis Hey Joe dispenza yeah so I
would always I always knew always
happened to you yeah that's great uh so
I knew I wasn't alone ever but you do
feel alone you know even if you know
that information you're speaking right
to my heart yeah I was thinking about
that this morning I was like something
ROM dogs used to say is if I know all
this why am I still here like what am I
doing if this is a classroom and we have
to figure out what you're saying it's it
can be frustrating I think it's fun do
you believe we choose our parents
yeah yeah I think I actually I'd go
farther and say
uh I'm a character in my own dream and
you're a character in my own dream and
the whole dream is a booby trap to make
me trip back into the love that I really
am but everything is orchestrated by not
me but by the one mind that we all share
yeah but it's it's it's
um benevolent it's it's it's arcing
towards love you would say it's trying
to trick you into waking up even if
you're suffering or whatever so not only
my parents it doesn't stop there I
not Pete but I made the guy that cut me
off in traffic today that I would have
an opportunity that's the part I
struggle with it's like I created all
this background noise like yeah I made
it this busy at the airport in this
dream world that is supposedly fake and
I struggle with that all the time you're
just like I make this silly joke like I
stubbed my toe that fell [__] real to
me you know what I mean my friend says
if it's all one whose headache is this
because pain is real yeah so what is it
at the root of the pain what I'm sitting
right now of course in Miracles would
say that we feel guilty that we broke we
separated from God so if it's all one
what are we doing here and there's this
liar in our minds our ego that says well
you wronged God there's a Greek myth
about stealing fire from the gods and
running out and that's life so we took
the light of God life itself and we
stole it to be specialist I'm with you
all of this is [__] yeah but it's
what we unconsciously believe and that's
too painful so we create parents that
give us uh trouble we create people
cutting us off in traffic we create
horrible [__] so we can go it's them
it's projection let's go it's them it's
not us because the guilt is too
unbearable I'm not saying that's
necessarily literally true that's what
I'm [__] with right now that's what
I'm [__] with too and it's just like
everything's a mirror and it's supposed
to teach you a lesson and it's yeah I'm
not like that that guy's a piece of [__]
right I think the lesson is if you want
to believe that you are innocent that
piece of [__] has to be innocent I tell
you that as someone who just 10 minutes
ago is complaining about my parents yeah
and then you you turn and you go
I know it's hard but I have to go like
the the more I
study whatever I'm even studying I don't
I don't I'm not the most articulate with
it but I just love all this stuff it's
oh no I already had the ADHD I lost my
train of thought
part of the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our
wonderful friends at betterhelp Getting
to Know Yourself can be a lifelong
process especially because we're always
growing and changing and like before I
went to therapy I had no idea what
codependency was or how to end a
relationship in a healthy way or how to
set up boundaries with family or people
I work with but that's what therapy is
all about deepening your self-awareness
and your own understanding of your life
and of your own Dynamics because
sometimes we don't know what we want or
why we react the way we do until we talk
through things with a professional
better help connects you with one of
those professionals with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are because the more you know about
yourself the more easily you can
maneuver through life with less
suffering and more clarity relationships
grief loss anxiety you name it talk
therapy has been so profoundly and
deeply helpful to both me and to Valerie
talking with a professional helps it's
greater than the sum of its parts seems
like you're just talking but it goes
deep and makes lasting change so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire and get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com
weirdo today to get 10 off your first
month and support the show support
yourself that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo we're also
brought To Us by our friends at next Evo
my favorite CBD company I love summer
summer means taking trips and traveling
with my family that's you know it's not
always easy travel is stressful it can
be hard on your body and it can be
disruptive to your sleep so whether you
need to de-stress or keep your sleep on
schedule keep it on track this summer
CBD can absolutely help and next Evo
Naturals is absolutely my favorite they
knock it out of the park the two
criticisms that I hear when I talk to
people about CBD is that it takes too
long to kick in and they don't feel it
next Evo is a different kind of company
they have figured it out with something
they called smart sorb technology it's
proven to be 30 times better absorption
in the first 30 minutes and four times
the overall absorption as other products
that means it kicks in quickly and it
absorbs truly and honestly and
completely so you can get that dose just
right and you know how you're going to
feel almost right away so not all CBDs
created equal a study by an independent
lab confirmed some Brands contain up to
60 percent less CBD than they claim on
the label but with next Evo you can
trust you're getting the best of the
best they just test it multiple times to
ensure you get a hundred percent of
what's on the label and you can tell
their stress gummies are CBD and whole
plant ashwagandha those are Lifesavers
when I'm feeling overwhelmed and anxious
if I'm stressed and just can't get on
with my day can't face my inbox can't
handle travel can't handle the summer
can't handle company they are my secret
weapon to round out the edge doesn't get
me back ready to face my day if you've
tried CBD before and didn't get it or
you didn't like it trust me next Evo is
different give it a try and leave summer
stress behind and upgrade your CBD Go to
nextevo.com weird to get 25 off plus a
free bottle of Premium pure CBD as a 50
value limit one per customer I love
their pure premium pure CBD especially
when you're fasting you don't want to
take any any calories whatsoever you
take it as a pill it's awesome that's n
e x t e v o.com slash weird support your
body support the show get 25 off
nextdevo.com weird alright everybody
back to Craig
have you done Ayahuasca yet no yeah have
you yeah
[Applause]
only eight times yeah eight times I'm
going back for nine and ten in a week
let me ask you a very very simple
question because it's complicated yeah
do you like it
uh yes and no it is it is uh
you go to
hell so to speak you can yeah you can if
you choose that you go do the shadow
work and you fight stuff you feel like
the medicine asks you if you want to do
that yeah you're in you co-create with
it 100 they teach you that I have a very
safe Circle and they teach you that and
how it's like Choose Your Own Adventure
and if you're in the depths of some
trauma or whatever you're battling and
uh you can just say this is too much for
me right now let's go to love and light
and then just like that have you done
that yeah you've done that yeah because
that what you just said is the closest
I've come to being like okay because I
just don't want that involuntary just
the bathtub gushing out of like you know
everything you're not ready for and
there's many misconceptions you do not
poop your pants you're in control like
the shaman
diapers first hundred times he was so
scared wow and then he's like after like
80 times and not poop and he's like what
am I doing I think I just like wearing
diapers
like that was his Revelation [__] I just
like that snug wouldn't you like a
diaper on you know what I mean I put
them on my baby yeah my girlfriend's so
safe dude for real my daughter is four
and a half she's about to be five she
the other night asked me to put a diaper
on her just because she just sometimes
you just want to feel like a baby yeah
that innocence that beauty that that's a
sidebar so tell me okay so you to Choose
Your Own Adventure you co-create with it
yes I would I would say that that's sort
of similar to what we're doing here but
in a more extreme way so tell me the
story I will go back to the first time
you did it but tell me the story of a
time you can remember where it was
getting it was confronting you a little
too much and you were like let's stop
I uh
yeah I was fighting my liver I I felt
like the devil it felt creepy I hate
even saying that name the pandemic maybe
start getting all religious thing
somebody speak spiritual I don't think
you're alone there yeah and uh I just
remember
like purging this this beautiful soul in
the corner saying this song I Am light
and and it literally
it sound I don't I I know what I sound
like but it was like her light expelled
negative entities out of us that's how
it felt and uh the beautiful thing about
Ayahuasca is you're purging you're
vomiting uh but it's actually a
detoxifier so you're getting rid of
heavy metals pork poisons probably
microplastics it cleans you up on a
physical uh level now that they're
scientifically studying this there's
data behind this [__] but then in the
spiritual realm an emotional realm
you're literally vomiting like maggots
and you're going you're in but it's it's
uh
you're getting rid of addiction and and
and abuse and molestation whatever
people are there to heal from atrocities
yeah and uh and I give the analogy like
this because it's too hard to
encapsulate in any definition it's just
a vast ocean of Love Of Consciousness
that you tap into that even the what do
they call the quantum field or something
sure if you want to be sciency or love
or light or Eternal Light yeah and you
uh you just expel these demons and and
it just like get rid of [__] like
actually heal you know how you say like
you forgave someone yeah but then you
don't yeah on the sauce I could just
call it the sauce you let's do
you do you actually do your face you let
it go oh you let this wait and you just
feel like oh the analogy it's like a
deep tissue uh massage how it can be
extremely painful but then they pop it
that stress yeah and then you're free
they work it out you're free and right
and that's how you feel you because the
way life through yeah we're a real
go-around oh yeah it seems to me like
iOS because like no let's go through go
through yeah like through the you're
avoiding this about yourself or you're
avoiding that that happened to you am I
am I putting words in your mouth no you
do it's I was trying to just get it all
I'm trying to remember you experience
hive mind too like I've never I've
always been a hippie and I've always
believed in this stuff but then to
actually experience it yeah like I love
Bill Hicks I love like the enjoy the
ride it's for your love and I downloaded
that data long ago but then when I do
Ayahuasca I'm like oh this is this is
fact verification you're talking click
yeah you know and I go oh and you get
downloads and like like messages like
that's what I'm here for to build the
hill to help yeah the addicts the
junkies yeah and the choice between fear
and love that's that's of Course in
Miracles that's the whole thing is like
don't be afraid of God learned that you
could say he's your father or she's
she's your mother or it's you yeah one I
just wrote on my mirror our will is one
meaning God's will is my will not Pete's
will yeah but my my real self and what
God wants is the same thing which is
really powerful it is I've also been
saying to myself lately just be nobody
like I'll be at a party and I'm
overwhelmed and I'm like it's because
you're wondering what Pete should do and
I go just be nobody and you can yeah you
go there's like a zero place where
you're just like might be weird I've
been saying I am God well that that's
what I mean okay that that it's the same
sort of idea I am God is great though
it's a little more positive than just be
nobody I have to do that one for that
reason because it's more positive it's
more self-worth and that's what I go to
Ayahuasca there for self-worth healing
and uh let go you know forgiveness and
when you were being confronted you said
to it this is too much for me oh yeah
yeah I was battling that was the
craziest [__] I've ever experienced in
my life because that was the first time
I could say like I had a religious
experience I don't really go to church
this is my church The Ayahuasca Church
yeah sure and uh that I'm down with but
I just you know
the big organizations got a little
manipulated so sure and uh so you're
battling this [__] in my liver and it
was just so dark and that was and I felt
like light coming in through old girl's
voice in the in the corner singing I am
light and they have music just
everyone's a musician there and they're
singing these beautiful ikaros that are
indigenous to these tribes and they're
uh they said it's like the analogy the
birds chirped to the flowers to open it
up they sing the songs in the circle to
open you up to expel these garbage you
know ways whatever it is and uh yeah I
just remember it getting too much and I
was like I can't do this [__] let go and
I literally felt like a like a hand and
that's when I was like what the f what
the [__] was that I don't know if it was
my mind I felt something was holding up
and then you go and I couldn't that's
what I did it shared in this sharing
circles like the grip like I just kept
being like cause I'm fighting them you
know whatever it was negative
[__] and and I was like the grip he had
on me I was like what is this and I felt
like the the songs and oh they have
tuning forks and Tibetan singing bowls
and frequency machines and this shit's
hitting me and that's when I had like
the religious experience so to speak
where I started doing breath work I
didn't know I knew how to do
you know what I mean and I I was I was
doing love and light coming in this way
expelling bad [__] this way just
intuitively yeah yeah like sitting
upright straight spine like more you
know like all of a sudden um somebody's
guiding me it wasn't me bro yeah and the
tuning forks and you start like like
moving in motions it's very tribal like
uh nothing I was about to be funny and
be out of the moment but I was like I
started pounding my chest I'd really do
that now though it's very powerful say I
love you and hit your heart and uh no
really oh yeah yeah in the mirror and it
just helps get that heart centered come
on push it into your body kind of yeah
and just it was too much and I was
purging and I got rid of it that's what
I say like I said on my podcast like I
fought the devil I didn't kill him but I
got his legs you know we got rid of half
that [__] and it's just uh
unbelievable
and who actually made me go was what was
the breath work
it just was like I was doing it reminded
me this is how I don't even know the
name of it but do you know the Hulk when
the when Edward Norton's getting breath
work uh from one of the Gracies in the
beginning to to hold down his anger no
it reminded me of that like I started
doing breath work like I saw in a movie
Once wow but it was real breath work it
was like some Wim Hof [__] like I can't
even replicate it right now and I
[__] did it oh you were just on the I
was divinely Guided by Source because
you dip your toe into the Consciousness
that's where it's all there it's all
there you never want to leave that's
what I mean like now I know when people
die why they say like and they get
brought back like why'd you bring me
back yeah it's a reoccurring theme that
they all say if she talked to any ER
doctor I go down YouTube rabbit holes I
like this stuff yeah and I touched the
pond and it's just sacred geometry in in
in
and this ocean of Love really well I was
curious how visual it is how how much of
it is an overwhelming like are you in
the room oh you're in the room uh you
can only get to the Visions if you
meditate if you quiet your mind really
it's not like an involuntary if your
mind's too
powerful if you have ocd'd in the
millionth degree
it's hard to get there that's also why I
keep going back it's like of the eight
times I've done it I've went to the love
pond six I missed two and what were
those like they're still beneficial
they're still you didn't get to immense
self-reflection and deeper understanding
of oneself but do you want to touch the
love you know yeah and then so you touch
it and the shaman taught me he's like
it's the most beautiful thing on earth
and it heals you so go there and touch
it stay there maybe about 30 minutes but
that's when you get the work done so
once you're done in the pond of Love Of
Consciousness light whatever you call it
that's when you say show me more show me
more and then you could go to bad places
and like fight once you're in withholds
and with love it's like once you trust
reality yeah you're brave enough
it's like it's funny that you say that
it's like raising my daughter
I'm really proud at how Fearless she is
like this is going to sound absurd but
she'll hit me and I'm like yeah because
you're not afraid of it it's like my
proudest thing you know what I mean yeah
like she just clocks me she's playing
she's yeah
she'll just hit me I'm like yeah because
you trust me and when you trust God like
that you're like okay what do you want
me to learn yeah and that's like kind of
what we're yeah maybe here to do is
learn how to for sure trust that's what
they say too it's uh Shadow work or what
we call Shadow work I don't yeah
understand it but I just know uh I've
never felt lighter and lighter and
that's also why I keep coming back and I
also thought I was gonna be one and done
and healed but it's just like layers
does it linger layers I hear you uh yeah
yeah it lingers for a week to two weeks
afterwards you're real high on God and
everything's beautiful more beautiful
than usual um
can you see the Miracles and everything
from that bush to that camera that's
working you know right oh my God don't
get us started I mean it's everywhere
it's crazy it really is even we were
talking about my parents this is a good
weed story
I took 2.5 my like because I after a
long time it does I don't want to do it
when I'm with them because I feel like
my guard is down I feel too exposed but
that night I went home and I took a a
2.5 or and I in a genuine way not a
gaslighting myself way I was laughing
and going like oh my God they're perfect
and I really meant it not like I love
everything they do and I like everything
they do I just meant like nobody is like
them they're really incredible yeah
whether or not I like it or don't like
it I saw them as this like distinct
unique phenomena if that makes sense I
had an appreciation no I I uh I agree
I'll have experiences like that like oh
they're perfect the way they are and
then like five minutes later you're like
shut the [__] up yeah yeah yeah yeah let
me tell you this in case it makes you
think of something I did five Meo DMT
which
Ayahuasca is DMT
I love how us hippies know like die
methyl tripped at me like we know all
the chemistry it's so silly the shaman
doesn't like that he doesn't he wants
you to do it natural yeah his what he
said was like don't do that that's man
the syrup is fermented in the jungle for
thousands of years and this is what
synthetic debt a decade old you know
he's like wow he's like don't do that
wow and I was like I've never talked to
somebody I'm like first of all I would
do it with you there's something about
you come with me the 18th
your face when you talked about
forgiveness I saw it on your face I saw
somebody that has experienced the joy of
forgiveness because you say you do and
you don't you're like I forgive you I
forgive you and you have this yeah it's
not a mental act it's a miracle
forgiveness is a miracle and you need to
like receive it but you don't think your
way to it no you surrender your way to
it I don't know how to achieve it
without mushrooms or Ayahuasca I'm
working on it you know I don't want to
have to yeah although it is a beautiful
medicine it's not it's no problem like
once I started going in these circles
and the guy's done it 800 times and he's
a lawyer and has three businesses I was
like oh this is fine yeah this is wow
everyone who does does this a lot is
they have a glow you could you could
feel it in the room well it's like the
people when I go to the program the room
rooms there's like two people in there I
want to be like and they're the people
with 30 40-year sobriety this that level
of surrender yeah like a stone yeah yeah
and the wrestling
we're all here to be like them right I
would say this syrup is like a shortcut
to you know I don't wanna I don't want a
30 you know I want it now do you have
you ever had that experience I want to
tell you my five Meo story but do you
get the sense that when you're there
that it like used that lawyer and his
glow and his story to kind of not trick
you but to coerce Craig to do it like it
loved you so much that it was like don't
you see a hid in a Vine and I hid in a
some bark of a tree and I made Ayahuasca
thing and I I you heard about it it was
like a seduction if that makes sense I
get the feeling like I don't know 100 no
it absolutely you understand and I feel
like because it's a spirit it's a spirit
and once you start doing it like keep in
mind I'm a comic and I was very
judgmental in making fun of these people
and then now I'm like I make jokes but
I'm like hey where'd you get that Poncho
you know like now I'm like I want all
the stuff happy where'd you get that
tool you know and uh and in the
beginning I'm like what the pan flutes
yeah you'll be the first pan flute it's
a spirit and it's it's Awakening as we
are Awakening because it is time well
this is what I mean by our willing to
Earth and what's coming yes and how
these negative
Psychopaths that have this current
[__] system that's all a lie this
this is what I scam have you heard of
earthships and free energy what is that
you don't know the earthships no I
almost I bet this uh place in New Mexico
where they build homes into the land and
it's like 90 to 100 percent
self-sufficient and it's cheaper to
build and it's made with trash Michael
Reynolds builds them he's been doing it
30 40 years Earth ships they call their
ships they just build it into the land
and it's you mean like Santa Fe like it
looks like a little yeah Adobe kind of
thing yeah and it goes with the flows of
Nature and collects the sun this way and
holds the heat because they build it
into the Earth I'll send you a link your
mind's gonna be blown it's gonna be all
these Simple Solution like that that
could solve The World's problem but it's
not being pushed but they just take our
money and you know give us drugs instead
right and McDonald's is legal you know I
was just talking to somebody about that
where I was like they don't care they
don't care yeah they don't care if they
cared they'd get rid of the cancerous
poisons in our food that are illegal in
all the other countries but somehow are
illegal here right I just learned about
microplastics and forever chemicals and
that's just like I need to stop learning
this [__] yeah because you just go oh
it's heavy it's all of it it was I feel
like there it I don't want to put down
another country but I saw a post that
was like even here I don't it doesn't
matter what it was but they were like
this is illegal and it's in our food and
I was like [__] nuts it was um father
Greg Boyle who wrote tattoos on the
heart which is incredible if you haven't
already you got to read it or listen to
it I was how did you know I was like I'm
an audible guy listening to it listen to
it yeah no I am him too I love books but
on Audible me too you're dyslexic I just
read and I don't get it and I was just
oh I was just listening to something
that was like we've only been reading as
human beings for like 500 years but
we've been listening for thousands of
years so we're way better at listening
you've been making me feel a lot better
about myself I love you people I love
you that's what I was getting in my head
like why do you only like audible
because it's like you said about the
plan it's like this is old listening is
old reading is new yeah we're still in
the baby steps are reading daddy that's
right suck a dick higher education I'm
sorry I couldn't read your boring ass
textbooks [__] suck now look at me
now yeah and now you read my book I'm
funny
I made it I meant magooby do you know
how good it is to not be a fantastic
reader I read every day but like I'm not
tearing through books you know how great
it feels to write a book when you
haven't read
I have read hundreds of books but I'm
saying I'm not like I don't consider
myself a reader and at the same time I'm
like and I wrote a book it feels really
nice I can't wait to write a book yeah
scam it that's what I'm saying Ghost
Rider it'll be
you'll still have it on your shelf and
you won't read it
what were we saying what were we saying
we were talking about Ayahuasca we're
talking about oh microplastics oh and
father Greg Boyle so we were talking
about how he changed the names of the
homies in his book so if he writes a
story he'll change the name and he was
like we were talking about the legal
department and he was like if the story
is about someone who's past the legal
department doesn't care if I change the
name the people that are like you have
to change all the names unless they're
dead and then you realize oh you don't
care this isn't like it's masked the
legal department is masked in a fake we
are loving and we care but they don't no
we just don't want to be sued no they
just don't want any legal trouble and
there's something liberating about that
and the food companies when I say they
don't care
and weed I'm not trying to say no don't
care we got bought up by William Morris
and they're dirty now too oh really yeah
they try to make it illegal forever and
Lobby you know they and then uh yeah now
they bought tons of land and humble and
the in the Triangle I'm a weed guy yeah
I know my my wife is from Humble the
same people the tobacco people that were
lobbying against it and pushing for
people to be in jail for are now buying
up all the land and they own medmen that
trendy little weed shop is Marlboro or
whatever I said William Morris not them
yeah yeah not WME yeah but there is like
a William Morris that yeah something
else I forgot all the technicalities
bottom line big tobaccos buying up all
the weed and pushing out the little guy
because wheat is a beautiful thing of
all these healthy hippies that sun and
soil and bat guano but then these big
large companies come in is pesticides
make it produce produce right and so
there's an innocence and a natural thing
to it when used at a medicine but of
course with this conglomerate Industrial
Systems everything that's in there and
then it ruins it yeah it always ruins it
I was watching something about the way
when you harvest when you grow things
like a corporation so corporations
always just want to grow it's growth
over anything else growth over Humanity
growth over Humanity that Village is in
the way exactly where these chemicals
are killing people but it increases
profit so you just do it we're doing
that in the crops as well meaning the
way crops are supposed to work is
there's a season let's say corn grows
and then it dies and then that death
fertilizes it and enriches the soil and
the next season the corn grows but
there's all that death time and we're
like these I've said this a million but
like we're inhale only [__]
yeah we're like growth only
[__] and you reference it's a
newer sustainable he goes something that
only grows is a monster it's a cancer
yeah it's literally what cancer does
people are waking up though we it's
beautiful can be cancer you know what I
mean like zoom out and think of us as
cells we can be cancer does that mean
like oh 100 literally to the Earth and
we are it has or we can smoke for the
Earth and for the for the I don't know
how much we can affect the solar system
but the planet is a body yeah exactly
sure who knows
anyway sorry I went no no I love that no
because we are a Cancer to the world and
really from Cobalt mines to to oil my
whatever that's right to Green energy
The Bad The Big Oil
we only want corn growing all the time
yeah I just did a bit about this I don't
know if I can make it work but I was
like you don't want what you want you
want to be surprised by what you want
you want what you want but you want it
on terms that you don't control because
I had my friend come over and play video
games because the only time we get to
play video games is at a birthday party
for my daughter and we get 10 minutes to
play and we have to sneak it and then
she comes in and catches us and we have
to stop or let her play exactly but so I
had him come over and we played and we
were like bored within five minutes and
the other example I give is like the
best back rubs of my life are not at the
Four Seasons where I pay someone
hundreds of dollars to rub my back you
know it's coming then you're critiquing
it you're like it's pretty good yeah but
if I just rubbed your shoulders like
behind you you're like it's like [__]
great and that's life we think we want
life to just be inhalation and just corn
growing all the time and not to Die the
whole thing is rigged to imbue it with
the only meaning I can which is the
urgency of time does that make sense uh
I use some big words yeah that no no
we've done whatever what time is it
it wasn't the big words it was the big
finish it was just oh well that was
condescending of me to say the big words
then forgive me forgive me and forget
but Ayahuasca forgive me like a real
forgive oh yeah wait I have to leave at
I have to leave at 11 45 I guess
ah [__] man it's always these good ones
no we're good man no I know I know I was
just taking a moment of appreciation for
your eyebrow work and also how fun this
is and how I don't want it no you just
get too deep for me sometimes to where
I'm on the beginning of my spiritual
journey where I'm just like I I uh it's
just it's hard to understand this [__]
and I struggle with it daily yeah you
know I think all I was saying was life
pleasure exists because there's a clock
on the game and you know you're gonna
die at some point that I get that but
you just help me because I'm making this
point on stage and I'm like why doesn't
anyone understand what I'm saying that's
a much better way it'll hit harder when
you yeah I said ice cream wouldn't be
delicious if you knew there was infinite
ice cream and infinite time that is true
and I do understand that completely
because the time clock tick tock tick
tock is what makes this enjoyable
because we are gonna die or go home go
home yeah you can never be created or
destroyed [__] that's right we're
energy that's right I love whether the
atheist that only believes in science
I'm like well science just told you yeah
there's something
you know it's been interesting is is
the ultimate Rebellion is to say God
doesn't exist that's that's the ultimate
way to say that we split off from
perfect Oneness so far and so
independently and so desperately and
we're such victims and everything is
[__] and we die and the food is
running out that that is this altar of
like God is dead like God is dead is the
ultimate goal of the ego is to say he's
dead my name's on this building he's
alive I have a hundred billion dollars
and it's horrible news because you're
afraid of God because you don't trust it
you go so far out of your way to say it
doesn't exist because you think he's
going to kick you in a furnace he's
going to be mad at you use whatever
pronoun you want God is going to this
this thing he's going to destroy you
because we destroyed him because we
exist in Duality and god is perfect love
so how did we get here so we must be mad
it's the Garden of Eden we ate from the
apple and he's mad at us but you have to
go like apple exactly or the apples
never existed in the first place it's
all just a little dance a little Play
It's harmless it's okay that I think the
whole point of this is to remember you
don't have to be afraid of your Source
you don't even have to call that God you
can just say yeah there is a body of
infinite light you can call it science's
words you can call it religions words it
doesn't matter you just have to learn to
trust it it'll change how you live it'll
change how you die if you trust and you
just feel better and for [__] sake you
just feel [__] better yeah yeah it
ain't on you a big few yeah a big pills
thank you who can be this who can be
disappointed who asks for what he
already has is a line from a course oh I
like that isn't that good it's hard to
hear who can be disappointed who asks
for what he already has and you just
have to remove you don't have to you
don't have to do anything you can do
whatever you want but you can remove the
impediments to the awareness of your of
yourself and just go no there's P Pizza
fresh today he's angry today [__]
impediments Craig smoking weed today you
know what I mean like there can be a
dispassionate
oh the analogy I love speaking of the
damn impediments is weeds I come weeds
this is the garden and you just say
always get the negative thoughts get it
out of there weed the garden oh yeah get
them let the seeds be bountiful yeah
because those stupid weeds you know how
many do we have they just won't shut up
I agree you know I think the fear is
that we're powerful beyond measure to
quote Yeah Marion Williams you're not
you're not afraid that you're [__]
you're afraid that you're everything I
can't wait to send you some links I
can't wait for these links have you
heard of Dolores Cannon and her stuff
I've never been to the Dolores Canyon
this weird lady from Arkansas that was a
hypnotist and spoke through uh a channel
yeah really crunchy Channel
everybody Nostradamus aliens like do you
want to go down some rabbit you want to
eat a gummy and watch some Dolores
Cannon
mind blown I love it though I love she's
my favorite in Dr Wayne Dyer and Louise
Hay and nap will ramdas yeah yeah there
he is so many so many great teachers
buddy I'm I get my education from
YouTube
is there anything better
that's what I want to say when we're
talking about booby traps right so
Ayahuasca booby traps you to remember
that your love the internet is all porn
and it's all [__] conspiracy theories
and then it goes guess what yeah but
then Earth ships come in and then
education comes in all of this stuff is
available
once you realize there's Solutions you
just it takes the weight off your
shoulder too just like people think
there's a shortage of food it's like no
we just don't Garden right get some
chickens right it's the solutions are so
simple collect rain water right
government stop giving the water to
Nestle wow how about that wow there's
been a drought every year since in
California that we signed a paper given
Nestle so much water for like six bucks
I don't know the real dollar amounts but
wow yeah people don't pay attention to
this stuff it's just it's it's all
abundant it's free right with a little
labor I scandalous
God comes back and sees we're all
fighting and stuff because we need money
and he's like why do you need money
because we got to buy food and he goes
food I left that [__] on the ground
is so true so so true see this is why I
like the course the course goes we don't
want to accept the truth of infinite
love Because We crave our individuality
we we would rather be miserable in
individuals than merge into Oneness it's
like on Star Trek you know how you're
afraid of the Borg because they've
assimilated into one mind I think that's
a pretty good and inaccurate view of our
fear of going back into Oneness as we go
we I'd rather be over here and I'm
speaking as me complaining
then just be perfect love how boring is
perfect love very boring it can be
pretty boring I can't wait to go back I
can't wait to be that kind of board man
no yeah that's uh yeah that's what we're
here for for the Spice they say this is
Dolores Cannon said this is the hardest
one too this is the realm yeah is the
hardest one oh wow and she says it's
because it's the only realm that we have
our memories wiped where we all come in
with the plan and purpose and innate
ability to do something and then they go
good luck and the rest you know what
you're supposed to dude it's the arcade
it's the cosmic arcade and you put a
quarter in the earth machine and people
are like really and you're like or
you're smoking something yeah I've all
I've said it before but it's like what
if when you die you you go away and then
you exhale and your friends are around
you go did it work
and you're like yeah oh yeah every
morning I wake up and my dreams I'm a
vivid dreamer and I'm a lucid dreamer
and I love my dreams it's great it
doesn't matter
I'm in the dream going don't don't
forget this and I'll remember point zero
three percent of it I know and I think
and it's a little bit weird to say this
I think that might be how it is when
this is over I'll go like
comedian like Dad I think I was a dad
vague like what did you dream last night
isn't it a relief to think that this
might just be like that according to
Dolores Cannon you experience everything
you've ever done in your life in a
moment and you also experience
how you made people feel from their
perspective oh wow and that's the hell
like she said there's no hell but the
Only Hell is experience the bad things
you did as the person you did them to
and that I don't know I like it oh well
yeah I don't know I who knows I could
see that that would be a game you might
play I would say it would be interesting
to talk to her I would say I agree with
you because people smoke DMT and have
that exact experience I experienced all
the suffering of the world in an instant
all of it so I know we can play any game
we want I believe that the mind can
create and and sort of miscreate
whatever it wants but behind it I would
say there's there is an ultimate God
going like are you done playing with
your balls and sticks and
putting on a little show for yourself
it's what Alan Watts says when the play
is over you go back and take your masks
off and and your enemy was you and you
were you yeah your friend was you and
and you just laugh it's okay you just
laugh so even that pain feels a little
bit like you're you are naughty oh Craig
you hurt my feelings so now you're dead
you're gonna feel how I felt when you
hurt my feelings or Craig we were just
puppets and the whole thing was being
orchestrated by
clear on that she's like it's quick it's
not you don't [__] her message was you
do not burn in hell for eternity it's a
brief moment and you're it's meant to
teach the purge to learn yeah you're
like oh you [__] up that's interesting
that's all it is and she gave me this
analogy because I was raised in the
Catholic Church Episcopalian I didn't
really download the data but I it still
was in me so to speak so you're afraid
of hell and The Burning Ring of Fire or
whatever and she said like
you're God's children right like would
you she has somebody in the audience
would you throw your kid in a fire and
they're like no they're like well then
why would God throw you in the fire it's
a lie made up by the church to get your
money yeah to make you feel guilty It
Was Written in later you know it sounds
like that adds up you know you said
something very similar
I say the camera JC
it's in the New Testament oh Jesus
Christ who did you say Joshua Scott
Chavez from from NSYNC JC
as I'm wearing a cross yeah yeah you
went to the your first chance
[Laughter]
yeah the NSYNC Jesus
um no he said I love Jesus who who would
give their child a snake when he asked
for bread Jesus was funny that's funny
that's like a that's three steps from a
one-liner you could have said like a
stick he said a snake when he asked for
bread yeah that's good good stuff I'm
down with JC that feels dope okay we
talked about all this God stuff and I
love it I have to ask you some questions
about one of your fa my favorite this
will be how we close if that's okay
we'll end on a laugh I could talk to you
for nine hours we got to do this again
yes you're so great thank you and maybe
the 18th I don't know yeah absolutely
recap we have to see I think it's for
anyway you love it you would love it
yeah the safest the shaman this Reiki
dude this guy's been sent with the
medicine like 20 30 years wow me I call
him Yoda like he's he's the Jedi he's
like I'm like
do you do it three days in a row or you
just do it for two days two days yeah
twice you do a two day Retreat yeah two
times
wow yeah where
um nature around yeah it's somewhere
beautiful uh I'm not asking for it no I
it's the illegal so yeah okay yeah but
somewhere beautiful over there somewhere
beautiful yeah yeah yeah yeah I know I
understand you just want to be somewhere
natural and beautiful yeah this is
convenient because it's local and you
don't have to go to Peru or Mexico right
you know because it's a little harder
word up yeah
okay real quick you do this bit about
getting fired from Trader Joe's which I
love thank you and every time you I've
seen you do I saw you doing in Montreal
I watched you do it on YouTube I just
have so many questions so tell the story
no you don't have to do the bit but I
have to ask you some questions I need
answers so tell the story first of all
you work seasonally at Trader Joe's and
then that ended up working at 10 yeah I
gotta I it's it's it's a joke but it's
not a joke I got hired at Trader Joe's
for seasonal work and I stayed over a
decade
11 years and I uh and then I was fired
uh uh because I farted on my manager and
filmed it and posted it to Instagram and
it went viral
oh that was part of the problem you got
picked up so what so there's there's the
stage version and the behind the scenes
the real version it's it's very close
though I did I was a jackass I was
filming stuff at Trader Joe's I'm a
comedian yeah it was I started going
viral yeah I remember I got message by
Tia Tia and Tamara Sister Sister sure I
grew up watching them yeah yeah they're
like you're so funny I was at Trader
Joe's and you know Tia Tamara love you
yeah and because I was I'd shake your
sodas and sell them to you but I was I
was loved I was loved like it was to an
old person but we're friends I give them
free bags or something you know like it
was it was a [__] I'd worked the milk
box I'd scaria and film you you know
and then just crate just chaos I'm a
jackass I was you know a kind one and
then just fun stuff and then I farted on
my okay first question
where on his body did you fart I farted
on him many times but the one I filmed
well there was a little barrier
okay so we're getting to it he didn't
fire you yeah yes okay so where did you
fart on him the time farted him and the
manager area the pit they call it the
pit at Trader Joe's and I said hey
what's up fart ass and I said fart ass
and then I and then I farted on him
where just like Adam that was a that was
a barrier you know okay he was on the
other side of register I wasn't on them
yeah but I had in the past you have
placed one on it oh yeah but not this
time oh yeah we we're always you know he
laughed it's cold yeah he's my buddy and
then uh filmed it posted an Instagram
went viral a customer ratted me out to a
manager at another store like up north
like Oregon or something they went to
corporate wait they showed some just
citizen like a neighborhood watch yeah I
was like I'm gonna show this to a
manager at another Trader Joe's yeah
because you farted yeah and it started
to pick up it was daily it was daily
it's hard to pick up the inner Steam
yeah and then uh corporate told my
manager to fire me and this guy was my
friend this guy literally went to my
show Saturday and fired me like Tuesday
or Wednesday he was a fan and a friend
and we're still we still text oh wow and
the whole joke but he's reading me the
corporate script like it's been brought
to my attention you've been posting on
social media and and you know I'm like
dude you're in the video like I tagged
you in it
and uh but it's true and then they let
me go but it was it was the most I was
ready to quit
because the stand up and this was God's
way I was too scared to quit because I
was maxed out at 24 an hour and I had
full benefits they gave me time off for
stand up they knew I was funny they knew
I had a path so it was kush it was easy
streets and then God was like you gotta
let go of that and you gotta fly and
then it took them firing me and I was
there 11 years you know that's all I
knew
and it was it was of course you know I
felt sick and scared and then and then
it all happened JFL I met you I got reps
I started headlining and it just like it
was all the video helped getting fired
for that that bit is so good the bit's
good but it also helps your life you
helped my life it helped me grow as a
fan base as a performer wow I still try
not to do those jokes and the fans
literally Will shout them out and be
like do Trader Joe's I'm like damn it
but I yeah
it really speaks to another Well
sandwich this with compliments when I
watch you do it there's some guys you
watch and you're like well what's the
new material there's some guys you just
want to hang out with and your fans just
want to hang out with you you know what
I mean yeah that's why I was like I
don't normally ask people about bits but
I'm like it's just fun oh thank you
hearing you talk the way you talk the
way you think and the way you are that's
why I understand that you could prank
like if you jumped out of a milk carton
at Trader Joe's if it was you that's
kind of what I mean when I'm like I
would do Ayahuasca with you like you
know what I mean
about your energy that you're like I
feel like I'd be okay as long as I could
look over and Craig's in the diaper yeah
it's going like it's not for poop it's
because
diaper no that's crazy
and your podcast Clips are so great
you're always just having fun
being light it inspires me on this show
too I'm like don't forget to have fun
you know like I watch you and I'm like
right I go yeah that's my goal to be
light be like because it does go dark
you look out and you're like yeah
whatever right you're like you don't
know what to do but it's just just laugh
right like I love uh Anthony Bourdain
and he said this about chefs but chefs
are on the side of the Angels we're on
the side of the angels we make jokes
right we don't work for the bomb
machines right right we're doing the
Lord's work we just even if it's a
stupid bit or you know well somebody or
a deep one I think
we're all capable of of furthering
either fear or love at all times oh yeah
and I I think there are even comedians
that can further the fear one but I mean
like so and there might be bomb makers
that can further the god the love yeah I
don't mean by doing bombs I mean like
you know your day your whole day isn't
bombs yeah yeah they go home to their
family yeah or they whistle blow that
was that wasn't when father gray father
Greg's book he talks about
um some dude that's locked up being kind
to a guard because he was like because
if I [__] with him he goes home and what
he hits his kids yeah you know what I
mean like there's this awareness where
you go like even the guards even the
bomb makers like
it's Dr Bronner's we're back all one
yeah all one baby it's not easy to do
that no but we're we're working it we
are can you tell me thank you for
answering those questions I had so much
thank you for having me yeah man the
last question is can you think of a time
in your life when you laughed hard
really really really really really
really really really hard where you were
crying and you hurt it doesn't have to
be a good story you can just tell me how
old you were where you were who you were
with
um one time in Las Vegas with my father
and we went there two to four times a
year and uh and it was me and my mom and
my sisters and my father came home drunk
from gambling but in a good mood this
time and he uh I was asleep with my
mouth open and he was drunk and started
putting random items in my mouth as a
kid
and uh
he put like his keys in his watch and I
didn't wake up and then he was laughing
like Harry and the Hendersons when he
throws the yogurt at the TV like yeah
and then I woke up to him laughing like
that and then we all started laughing
everyone's laughing like a cackling
hyena I don't even know what we're
laughing at but I'm just laughing I'm
half asleep so like that didn't even
register that I'm the I'm the joke and
we're cackling so loud that the The
Neighbor comes and bangs on the door of
the hotel like keep her down this is
like three four a.m oh my God and my mom
gets up and she doesn't have her teeth
in she has no teeth and her Dentures are
out and the guy's like tell your kids to
shut up in there like an old man in
tighty whities too tighty whities and
then she said it's not in my kitchen my
husband and it's and it's been a joke in
my family for about 25 years my pictures
my husband and we laugh and laugh
[Laughter]
my husband
look good that can help it that helps
The Voice and when did you realize there
was a watch in your mouth that's what
I'm missing and that's like the next day
or years later I didn't I wasn't aware I
just remember this is fun we're laughing
huh you know that's all I remember and
the tick tick sound from within but like
that guy
is there a bomb in my tummy
like cackling cackling [__]
incredible well Craig you are incredible
you're so funny you're so talented I
you're already killing it but I just see
even bigger and better for you moving on
so yeah go ahead I just that's it yeah
thank you man what's the name of your
pod because my podcast is community
service check it out yeah talk about
farts and sobriety and Drugs That's
great yeah well wishing you all the best
my man thank you would you say keep it
crispy it's how we end the guest says
keep it crispy keep it crispy with Pete
Holmes no no no it's just like keep it
quick no no no no you just say give a
crazy you don't say it keep
crispy
[Music]